PROFESSOR: So stability
has some value,
but it doesn't mean
that everybody's happy.
In fact, it just
means that nobody
can find anybody else who's
equally unhappy that they
would want to run off with.
So let's examine the
question of how well people
do using the mating ritual,
or in other possible ways
of finding stable marriages.
So basically, we want to begin
with the question of who does
better, the boys or the girls?
Maybe it's a mixture.
Maybe the boys do better,
the girls do better,
or maybe some boys do
better than others,
and some girls do
better than others.
One thing to notice is we know
that the girl's suitors are
getting better day by day, and
that sounds like the mating
ritual might be
slanted towards them.
Likewise the boy's
sweethearts, the ones
that they're serenading, are
getting worse day by day,
and that sounds like it might
be an argument for the girls
to do better, but
that's not true.
And the reason it's not is
that, if you think about it,
the boys are starting off
with their first choice.
They begin by serenading the
girl at the top of their list,
and it's true that
day by day they
keep going down, or staying
the same or going down,
but they're only
sinking to, in fact,
the best possible woman that
they could be married to.
Let's examine that.
So I need a definition,
which is that we'll
say that a woman, Nicole,
is called optimal for Keith
when she is the highest ranked
girl he can stably marry.
So let's think about
that for a minute.
So Keith has his preference for
different girls that he likes,
to different degrees, and there
may be some that he likes.
Like Keith thinks that
Angelina is terrific,
but there's just
no way that she's
going to wind up with
him, because she just
ranks him very lowly, so there's
no stable set of marriages
in which Keith can
wind up with this very
desirable woman, Angelina.
But if you look at all of
the sets of marriages that
are stable, that Keith
can be involved in,
among them Nicole is the
woman that he most likes,
so that's what we mean by
Nicole is optimal for Keith.
She's optimal among
the feasible women
that he could stably
be married to.
The claim that we're making
is that the mating ritual
yields a set of stable
marriages, which
is simultaneously optimal for
Keith and all the other boys
at once.
Now, that's a kind
of unusual thing.
Usually when you're
optimizing, you
figure you're
optimized for one boy,
and it sacrifices the
optimality for the other boys,
but that's not what happens
in the mating ritual.
All of the boys get their
absolutely optimal spouse
in the mating
ritual, and dually it
turns out that all of the girls
get the worst possible spouse
that they can get,
a pessimal spouse,
among all possible
stable marriages.
Well, with that
claim understood,
let's go about
proving it, and we're
going to prove that
the mating ritual leads
to boy-optimal marriages
by contradiction.
So let's suppose that Nicole
is optimal for Keith among all
the women that
Keith could possibly
be married to in a stable way.
Nicole is the best.
Suppose that Keith does
not wind up marrying
Nicole in the mating ritual.
So he doesn't marry Nicole
in the mating ritual.
That means that since the
Nicole is optimal for Keith,
he must be married
to somebody that's
less desirable to
him than Nicole,
so he must have crossed
Nicole off on some day.
Let's call that his bad day.
So on his bad day, Keith is
rejected by his optimal spouse.
OK
If this ever happens,
there's going
to be some boy who has the
earliest bad day-- we may
as well assume that it's Keith.
So let's assume that Keith was
the earliest among the boys
to have a bad day, that is,
a day on which he crosses off
his optimal spouse, because
he was rejected by her.
Well, on this bad day when
Keith crosses off Nicole,
it's because Nicole
rejected him,
which meant that Nicole had a
suitor that she liked better
than Keith.
Let's call that suitor Tom.
So what we know is that Nicole
prefers this guy Tom to Keith
on the day that she rejected
Keith, and he crossed her off,
and we also know since
this is the earliest
bad day that anybody
has, Tom has not yet
crossed off his optimal girl.
So what that means is that
since he's serenading Nicole,
and she's going to wind up
rejecting Keith in favor
of Tom, it must be the case
that Nicole is at least as
desirable to Tom as
his optimal spouse,
because he hasn't gotten
to his optimal spouse yet.
He's working his
way down the list,
and he hasn't had a bad day yet.
So let's put these
two pieces together.
Nicole is at least as desirable
to Tom as Tom's optimal spouse,
and Nicole prefers
Tom to Keith, but what
that tells us is that if I
had a set of stable marriages,
with Nicole married
to Keith, then
in the stable set of
marriages, of course,
Tom is going to be married
to somebody that's,
at best, optimal for him,
so he's married to somebody
that he likes less than Nicole.
And Nicole is married
to Keith, and she
likes Tom better than
who she's married to.
What that tells us is
that Nicole and Tom are
a rogue couple in any stable set
of marriages where Nicole was
married to Keith,
but that contradicts
the fact that Nicole is supposed
to be optimal for Keith.
There's supposed to be a
stable set of marriages where
Nicole is married to Keith.
So a similar argument-- it's
actually slightly easier--
is that the mating ritual
yields a set of stable marriages
in which all of the
girls get the worst
possible spouse
that they can have
in any set of stable marriages.
So this leads to a whole
bunch of questions,
and it turns out that
there's a very rich theory
of stable marriages,
as I mentioned.
First question to ask
is, well, are there
other possible stable marriages?
Well, one thing that
you can obviously do
is you could switch the roles
of the boys and the girls.
So if you switch the roles
of the boys and the girls,
you'll get a set
of stable marriages
that are optimal for the girls
and pessimal for the boys.
Maybe that's fair or
you rather do that.
So that's at least a possibility
of using the mating ritual
to get two different
stable sets of marriages,
unless the two happen
to be the same.
And the question
arises, are there
others that could exist that
the mating ritual doesn't find,
either by choosing the boys
to act as boys or the boys
to act as girls, and the answer
is that, in general, there
can be many.
As a matter of fact, if
there are N boys and girls,
it's possible that there
could be an exponential number
of stable marriages in N, and
that leads to the question of,
well, which is one that
might be a better one
to choose compared to the one
that completely favors the boys
or completely favors girls.
Another interesting
question that
comes up that's an
issue that comes up
with general protocols of
negotiation and optimization
among multiple parties is,
does it serve anybody to lie?
That is, instead of
following the protocol
and always going to the-- and
the boys always serenading
the girls that they like best,
and the girls always rejecting
anybody that's less desirable
than their favorite suitor,
suppose they violate
the convention and lie.
Can they do better?
Well, it turns out
that, of course,
the boys in the mating
ritual aren't doing optimal,
so they don't gain
anything by trying to lie,
but the girls it turns
out-- it's almost the case--
that girls can do
better by lying.
If they conspire
together to lie,
they can actually
force the mating ritual
to wind up turning into
a stable set of marriages
that's girl optimal.
So that raises
another issue about,
are there protocols which
are resistant to lying?
We're not going to go
into these questions.
We mainly wanted to
understand the stable marriage
problem and its applications
and how to find them.
Again, if you want to
learn more about this,
you can look at the book
by Gusfield and Irving
that I mentioned in
a previous video.